now i know many of you
were convinced
that last night about six o'clock local
time the world was coming to come to an
end
just because it has it doesn't mean
that it's not nearby
because my appearing today at yale
university is surely one of the four
horsemen of the apocalypse
but listen
today is your day
please
do not
turn off your electronic devices
leave your iphones your ipads your
sidekicks your droids your blackberries
powered up
recording
photographing texting out all that
emerges from this stage over the next
few minutes
by the way
i'm sporting the hat it ain't coming off
you know later on today you can compare
your tweets and your facebook comments
with those of others to figure out if
anything memorable went down
hey you know what tweet that last
sentence i just said
it'll give you something to do
give you something to do and
let your friends know where you are
today
okay then okay take this speech
and set it to music
and maybe insert some crazy kooky
graphics
star in that video yourself post it on
the web
and if it becomes a viral sensation
you'll be equal to any cat playing with
a paper bag
any set of twin toddlers talking
gibberish to each other
as popular as that cute girl that sings
about fridays hey
you could be the next samsui
such are just one of the possibilities
in our brave new world the world you now
inherit
whether you like it or not
the jig is up
the clock has run out in the future with
a capital f now rests with all of you
and your goofy hats
and all because
you went to yale
you are now the anointed
the charge holders
the best and the brightest
each of you a shining hope for our
nation in the world
you are the new wizards who can finally
make sense of all the delta vectors and
square roots and divided by's in the
theorem that we call the human race
the generations before you came of age
took on the job
now it's your turn
welcome
you know i once had a friend who had a
rich uncle
who promised to pay for his college
as long as my friend wished to stay in
school
you should stay in school as long as you
can the rich uncle said because would
you get out of college
you got to work every day for the rest
of your life
and you all will come to understand what
that rich uncle meant just as surely as
you will someday wonder where the hell
you put your reading glasses
and yell at your own kids to turn the
damn music down
on spring days like today it's
traditional for us to ponder the state
of the world and implore you all to help
make it a better place which implies
that things are somehow worse today
than when we up here were where you are
sitting right now i'm not so sure the
planet earth
is in worse shape than it was 30 no 18.
no four years ago
but that's not to say it's in better
shape either
refraining from waxing nostalgic and
comparing our then to your now and
avoiding the any talk of you kids these
days with your rap and your hip hopping
and your snoopy dog daddies with the
ditty pops
with your 50 cents and your quarter
cents
a sober look shows that just as the
world has gotten to be a better place
after all it has also grown a bit worse
at the exact same rate
a one step up one step back sort of
cosmic
balance between forward progress and
cultural retreat
that puts mankind on a bell curve of
existence
that shows a small segment in joy ease
and comfort while an equal proportion
struggle on
with little hope in the fortunes of the
remainder either on a rise or on the
wane in this confounding tide of so many
damn things that we grow oblivious to
the shifts in the quality of our lives
graduation day
is a proper occasion to put a toe in the
global waters and i think the mercury
shows
that things are much as they always have
been
ten years ago
we busied ourselves with trivial stuff
imbued with importance and then came
911.
in 1991
riches were created in new businesses
that had never existed then that
economic balloon burst in 81
i had a great job on tv
and in 82
bosom buddies was cancelled
in 71 color tv and more living rooms had
ever showed young americans still
fighting in combat in vietnam and in 61
satellites being live images around the
world for the very first time but those
images were of the building of the
berlin wall now this 10-year grid shows
the same yin yang thang and i'm trying
to copyright that
yin yang thang
copyright tom hanks
it shows the same
yin yang thang thank you on graduation
day 2011. you know we all have these
devices that can make a permanent record
of revolutionary change on the other
side of the globe
as well as hateful diatribes from across
town fewer and fewer in our country go
to bed hungry
but did you see how obesity now affects
about half our population
no matter how many bargains we find at
the local umart
many of us still struggle to pay the
rent and the utilities
our country is no longer physical or
even ideological war with our enemies
for most of the last century but in the
eleven and a half years of the third
millennium
our armed forces have been fighting on
the field for nine of them
purchasing intellectual property and the
work of artists we admire is as simple
as clicking a mouse and paying
less than a few bucks
which means
you may find that there is no guarantee
in making a living at your chosen
discipline
now some advantages particularly to this
age are not to be denied boredom
seems to have been vanquished
there is always something to do
but hasn't this translated into a
perpetual distraction in our lives
in the bathroom
at the dinner table
in the back seat
at a wedding at a bris
at a graduation day
there's always
something to check something to tweet
someone to watch something to download
something to play something to share
something to buy someone on a voicemail
something to yank at our attention span
and it's all in the palm of our hand for
a
small monthly service fee
that same technology
has allowed for a surplus of
celebrities
and that is nothing to cheer about
anyone
although that's sam suey he rocks
anyone can enjoy the perks of notoriety
now and the duration of fame
has been lengthened from andy warhol's
brief 15 minutes
to a good 15 months
if you're willing to do certain things
on camera
though orwellian language is often the
vocabulary of official news speak his
boogeyman that was the all-seeing big
brother has never emerged
unless you live in north korea
or run a red light in beverly hills
or shop online
or have done something stupid in the
wrong place at the wrong time in front
of someone with a camera in their cell
phone and that is everybody
so pardon my junior college latin the
vulgas populi has become the all-seeing
state and if you cross it google search
will forever display your screw up
so actually there is a big brother
but he's not a malevolent fiction he's
actually all of us and he lives in our
search engines
so no matter how many times i do the
calculations i come up with a social
draw
the positives balance the negatives the
x's
equal the y's
and our hopes weigh
as much as our fears but i hesitate on
that last one because fear good lord
fear is a powerful physiological force
in 2011.
we here up in the stands and surrounding
you graduating class
look to you as we do every year hoping
you will now somehow
through your labors free us from what we
have come to fear and we have come to
fear many things fear
has become the commodity that sells as
certainly as sex
fear is cheap fear is easy
fear gets attention fear is spread as
fast as gossip
and is just as glamorous juicy and
profitable fear twists facts
into fictions that become
indistinguishable from ignorance
fear is a profit churning go-to with a
whole market
being your whole family
you know sitting in the house
one day watching the game on tv not long
ago along came this promo for the local
nightly news
are our schools poisoning our children
that story in summer's hottest bikinis
tonight at 11.
in that i had school-aged kids at the
time i feared that they were in fact
being poisoned at school and
summer was still a few weeks away so
i tuned in
to get the scoop and the actual news
stories of that news broadcast was this
a certain supply
of hamburger
was found to have a bit too much of a
particular bacteria
in it and for safety's sake
was being taken off the market
that same hamburger was slated for sale
to an out-of-state school system for his
cafeterias but
it was recalled in time
so answering that news program's own
question in no
our schools were not poisoning our
children
but yes
that summer there would be some very hot
bikinis at the beach
now the early american naval commander
john paul jones said
if fear is cultivated
it will become stronger
if faith
is cultivated it will achieve mastery
and this is why i am a big fan of
history because observations of the
american colonies over 200 years ago by
a compatriot nathan hale who lived in
that building right over there
translate
there you go
translate word for word to the united
states in 2011. for i take that fear to
be fear in the large scale fear itself
intimidating and constant and i take
faith to be
what we hold in ourselves our american
ideal of self-determination
fear
is whispered in our ears and shout in
our faces
faith must be fostered by the man or
woman you see every day in the mirror
the former forever snaps at our heels
and our synapses and delays our course
the latter can spur our boot heels to be
wandering
stimulate our creativity
and drive us forward
fear
or faith
which
will be our master
three men found
that they could no longer sleep
because of their deep seated fears this
is a story i'm telling
their lives were in
a state of status because of their
constant worries so they set out on a
pilgrimage to find
a wise man who lived high in the
mountain so high up above the tree line
that no vegetation grew no animals lived
not even insects could be found so high
up in the mountains in that thin air and
when they reached his cave the first of
the three said help me wise man for my
fear has crippled me
what is your fear
ask the wise man i fear death said the
pilgrim i wonder when it is going to
come for me
ah death
said the wise man
let me take away this fear my friend
death
will not come to call until you
are ready for its embrace
know that
and you fear will go away
well this combat pilgrim's mind
and he feared death no longer
the wise man turned to the second
pilgrim and said what is it you fear
my friend
i fear my new neighbors
said the second pilgrim they are
strangers who observe holy days
different than mine
they have way too many kids
and they play music that sounds like
noise
ah
strangers said the wise man
i will take away this fear my friend
return to your home
and make a cake
for your new neighbors
bring toys to their children
join them in their songs and learn their
ways and you will become familiar with
these neighbors
and your fear will go away
well the second man saw the wisdom in
these simple instructions and knew he
would no longer fear the family who were
his neighbors
there in the cave so high in the
mountains that nothing could live
the wise man turned the last pilgrim and
asked of his fear
o wise
man i fear spiders
when i try to sleep at night
i imagine spiders dropping from the
ceiling and crawling upon my flesh and i
cannot rest
ah
spiders said the wise man
no [ __ ] why do you think i live way up
here
fear
will get the worst
of the best of us
and peddlers of influence count on that
throughout our nation's constant
struggle to create a more perfect union
establish justice and ensure our
domestic tranquility we battle fear from
outside our borders from within our own
hearts every day of our history
our nation came to be despite fear of
retribution for treason from a kingdom
across the sea
america was made strong and diverse
because here people could live free from
the fears that made up their daily lives
in whatever land they called the old
country
our history books tell of conflicts
taken up to free people from fear those
kept in slavery in our own states and to
liberate whole nations under the rule of
tyrants and theologies rooted in fear
the american cause at its best has been
the cultivation of a faith that declares
we will all live in peace when we are
all free
to worship as we choose
when we are free to express our hearts
and when we all seek
a place free from fear
but we live in a world
where too many of us are too ready to
believe in things that do not exist
conspiracies
abound divisions are constructed and the
differences between us are not
celebrated for making us stronger but it
calculated and programmed to set us
against each other
our faith is tested by unpredictable
providence and threatened when common
sense
is corrupted by specific interests
speaking from 54 years of experience
the work towards a more perfect union is
a never-ending concern that involves
each and every one of us
evidence that our nation is becoming a
better place is everywhere
but each new day fear is as the jersey
poet said lurking in the darkness on the
edge of town
your your rising from bed every morning
will give fear its chance to grow
stronger just as it will afford
faith its chance
to blossom
you will make the choice to react to one
or create the other
and because you are smart enough to earn
your place on this college day at yale
university you will sense the moment and
you will know what to do
in the meantime
ponder this front
in the struggle against ceaseless fear
and its ceaseless flow
in the coming months and years
veterans
of wars in iraq and afghanistan
will finally come home for good
after so many tours
and we know this
and we know this
some after many tours that wore on the
body aid to the soul and spilled a great
portion of their lives
for all of them
after a long time spent far away in the
harsh realm of war
and they returned different
from what they were
when they left surely their faith in
themselves
is shadowed by a fear
of not knowing what is expected of them
next now no matter what your view of
those wars over there you can affect the
future of our nation right here
by taking their fears head on
you can imprint the very next pages of
the history of our troubled world
by reinforcing the faith of those
returning veterans
allowing them to rest
aiding in their recovery
if possible their complete recovery
so let those of us who watched the
debate of their long deployments serve
them now as they served when they were
asked and as they were ordered
let's provide for them their place free
from fear
by educating them if they can learn
by employing them
as they transition from soldier back to
citizen
and by empathizing
with the new journey they are starting
even though we will never fully
understand the journey they just
completed
we all will define the true nature of
our american identity not by the parades
and the welcome home parties
but how we match their time in the
service with service of our own
give it four years
as many years are you spent here at yale
and acts both proactive and spontaneous
and do the things you can to free
veterans from the new uncertainty that
awaits them
from the mysterious fears
they will face the day after they come
home
cultivate in them the faith to carry on
and they will do the rest
so commitments day
arrives
your work begins
work that will not be always joyful to
you
labor that may not always fulfill you
and days that will seem like one damn
thing after the other
it's true
you will now work
every day for the rest of your lives
that full-time job
your career as human beings
and as americans
and as graduates of yale
is to stand on the fulcrum between fear
and faith
fear
at your back
faith in front of you
which way will you lean
which way will you move
move forward move ever forward
and tweet out a picture of the results
it may make you as famous
as sam sui
thank you
and congratulations